man tout le sens de la prochaine
élection présidentielle parce que c'est
là qu'il va falloir que les gens
apportent des réponses et moi je crois
que de toute façon on ne peut pas régler
les problèmes avec ceux qui les ont
créés et c'est impossible
[Musique]
ah bon ce soir à tous bienvenue pour
deux heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mercredi 7 avril à un
retour à la vie d'avant possible si 90 %
des adultes sont vaccinés d'ici
septembre selon l'institut pasteur en
étendant la sous traitance du vexin 16h
biotech a débuté sur le territoire quand
astrazeneca l' agence européenne du
médicament
elle confirme pour la première fois un
lien entre le vaccin et des caillots
sanguins mais précise que c'est un
phénomène rare le qui appelle les 27 à
parler d'une seule voix pour ne pas
nourrir la défiance
ja pour les france une sanction adressée
par amnesty international dans son
rapport annuel aux ong pointent
l'engagement du pays dans une voie
nocive pour les droits humains en cause
notamment un usage excessif de la force
des droits des migrants bafoués ou
encore des ventes d'armes irresponsable
et puis nous irons aux états unis où la
vaccination pour tous est devenu le mot
d'ordre joe biden place la barre encore
un peu plus haut à partir du 19 avril
tous les adultes devraient pouvoir
recevoir injection antico vide
se pose également la question de
passeport vaccinale elle se fait débat
outre-atlantique également
m
[Musique]
c'était un verdict attendu l'agencé
européenne des médicaments suggère
d'ajouter les caillots sanguins sur la
liste des effets indésirables rare de
l'astra zeneca pour la première fois un
lien en tout cas été fait entre
thrombose et vaccins en relativisant
toutefois le risque
les détails avec pierre jan masaryk un
possible lien entre l'astra et n'est
qu'à et la formation de caillots
sanguins
c'est le verdict rendu par l' agence
européenne des médicaments lors d'une
visio conférence très attendue la hem
qui suggère d'ajouter la formation de
ces thrombose à la liste de ce qu'elle
décrit comme de très rares effets
secondaires sans toutefois identifier un
facteur de risque spécifique sur la base
des résultats actuellement disponibles
des facteurs de risque spécifiques tels
que l'âge le sexe ou les antécédents
médicaux n'ont pas pu être confirmées
car les événements rares sont observées
à tous les âges aussi bien chez les
hommes que les femmes caisse in men and
women une explication plausible de ses
effets secondaires rares est une réponse
immunitaire au vaccin entraînant un état
similaire à celui observé chez les
patients traités à l'héparine un vaccin
efficace et qui sauvent des vies pour la
em qui précise que la balance bénéfices
risques est positive
même son de cloche du côté de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé qui
estime qu'un lien très rare entre le
vaccin et les caillots sanguins était
plausible mais non confirmée autre
réaction celle de l'union européenne qui
déclare appelé les 27 à parler d'une
seule voix pour ne pas nourrir la
défiance quant au royaume uni il
recommande de limiter le vaccin
astrazeneca aux plus de 30 ans alors que
mardi l'université d'oxford avait
suspendu les essais de ce vaccin sur les
enfants
les autorités sanitaires britanniques
ont précisé que sur 79 signalements de
caillots sanguins 19 personnes vaccinées
à l'astra zenica était décédé
tout ce sont plus de 20 millions de
doses du vaccin qui ont été administrées
dans tout le royaume
pendant ce temps en allemagne la région
de bavière dit avoir négocié l'achat de
doses de spoutnik v un contrat
préliminaire vient d'être signée en vue
de recevoir deux millions cinq cent
mille doses de ce vaccin russe sous
réserve de son approbation par le
régulateur européen et l'inde mais nous
la situation sanitaire ne s'améliore pas
alors que les habitants de sarrau
frontière du luxembourg et de la france
ont retrouvé bars et restaurants le
nombre de patients en soins intensifs
outre-rhin augmenté de 5% en une journée
agulla merkel et les dirigeants des 16
régions doivent se retrouver d'ailleurs
lundi pour négocier d'éventuels
d'éventuelles nouvelles mesures le
gouvernement se dit favorable de son
côté un cours confinement écouter pour
l'instant nous ne disposons pas d'une
base de données particulièrement bonne
en ce qui concerne le nombre de
nouvelles infections
mais le nombre de lits en soins
intensifs occupé parle de lui même
il augmente très fortement et beaucoup
trop vite les médecins en soins
intensifs sont inquiet et lance des
alertes
c'est pourquoi tous les appels à un
confinement cours et uniformes sont
justes il serait également important
d'avoir une approche commune à l'échelle
nationale car nous parlons de mesures
communes d'action commune et ce serait
souhaitable pour l'instant la variété
des règles qui ont été décidées ne
contribue en rien à la sécurité et à
l'acceptation et côté français toujours
sur le front sanitaires les
vaccinodromes poursuivent leur
déploiement sur le territoire en
seine-saint-denis celui du stade de
france opérationnel depuis hier va-t-il
diminuer le nombre de doses dont les
petites villes du département
l'inquiétude en tout cas et vivent l'un
et plus touché par l'épidémie ce
département où plusieurs élus dénoncent
un approvisionnement réduit david
khalifa vacciner massivement pour
rattraper un retard important c'est
l'objectif principal de l'exécutif avec
l'ouverture de ce vaccinodromes au stade
de france dix mille doses par semaine
doivent être administrés ici même
et puisque la france et le département
manque de doses il faut trouver ces
fameuses dos quitte à piocher dans les
communes environnantes
l'exemple de la ville de rosny sous bois
dans le 93 parle de lui même un centre a
ouvert ses portes le 23 mars dernier
avec l'objectif de vacciner 500
personnes par semaine puis rapidement de
passer à 1750 doses par semaine un échec
les livraisons à s'amenuisant le centre
a reçu 378 doses cette semaine et 200
sont attendus pour la semaine d'après
même son de cloche du côté de ce temps
où le maire de la ville montent au
créneau
on a entendu depuis maintenant depuis
depuis lundi des retards de livraison
des livraisons qui n'ont pas pu être
honorées
et visiblement il ya un lien il ya un
lien avec justement l'ouverture depuis
maintenant mardi du centre de
vaccination du stade de france malade
donc je pense qu'il faut être très très
vigilant parce que forcément ça va avoir
des conséquences sur un nombre encore
encore réduit de vacciner en
seine-saint-denis et pour les zones
rurales de l'hexagone c'est un problème
majeur de logistique qui vient s'ajouter
à cette pénurie d'eau notamment pour les
personnes âgées qui ne peuvent se
permettre bien souvent de faire 30
minutes de trajet pour se faire vacciner
ou bien de faire des queues à rallonge
comme ici même ou un stade de france le
gouvernement n'entend pas délaisser les
zones rurales qui représente 38% de la
population française les élus locaux
insistent sur la nécessité de
décentraliser et la possibilité pour les
maires préfets et sous préfets de faire
le lien avec l'état et les territoires
la mise en place de ces vaccinodromes
marque un pas de plus vers le tropisme
urbain dont fait preuve le gouvernement
on privilégie des solutions de
concentration obligeant les gens qui
habitent loin de ces centres à une
mobilité forcée alors qu'on pourrait
mettre en place d'autres solutions
l'important est de simplifier la vie des
gens pour ne pas les obliger à faire des
kilomètres inutiles alors qu'une
solution locale est possible on demande
la même attention pour la population
rurale que pour la population urbaine
l'ensemble du territoire est concerné
par cette nouvelle donne que l'exécutif
n'avait pas forcément anticipé car
alimenter ses vaccinodromes géant
pourrait risquer une pénurie d'eau dans
les petits centres de vaccination et
pourrait entraîner indirectement leur
fermeture
les annulations de rendez-vous
s'accumulent comme à rosny sous bois par
exemple et la compréhension demeure
parmi les habitants des communes les
plus reculées
celle de seine saint denis où d'ailleurs
sur le territoire et après le fiasco des
masques et des tests l'exécutif espère
bien on l'aura compris malgré un le
retard réussir sa campagne de
vaccination une sortie de crise qui lui
permettrait d'aborder plus sereinement
la présidentielle en 2022
arnaud montbourg à ce propos discret
depuis un moment déjà s'est d'ailleurs
exprimé sur ce sujet de manière assez
surprenante
dans une interview accordée au quotidien
britannique financial times consacré un
éventuel duel marine le pen emmanuel
macron et bien l'ancien ministre du
redressement productif il va de son
pronostic pour lui et bien c'est marine
le pen qui va l'emporter car
explique-t-il
le chef de l'état n'est pas un rempart
contre le rassemblement national
il compare cette victoire anticipé au
phénomène trump ou breakes site
alors comme le prédit arnaud montebourg
marine le pen va t'elle gagner
l'élection présidentielle de 2000 22
places à notre décryptage avec nos
syndicats
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler arnaud
benedetti rédacteur en chef de la revue
politique et parlementaire ou 7h
spécialiste de la communication
politique denis jacquet entrepreneurs
auteur également vous publié à la fin du
mois le début de la peur la faim d'une
démocratie aux éditions eyrolles et puis
alexis poulain qu'on connaît bien sur
notre antenne éditorialiste sur rt
france bonsoir messieurs merci à tous
les trois d'être en direct sur rt france
donc un an et un mois précisément de
l'élection présidentielle certains
candidats potentiels ne mâchent pas
leurs mots un parmi eux l'ancien
ministre socialiste de l'économie arnaud
montebourg gardéens ce qu'il dit du chef
de l'état dans les colonnes du financial
times macron il détester parce qu'il est
arrogant
ce n'est pas un rempart c'est lui qui
mettra madame le pen au pouvoir il vise
juste arnaud montebourg alexis poule 1
les mots sont durs 1 les mots sont durs
mais mesurée néanmoins on a vu
effectivement que ce fameux remparts
promis par emmanuel macron contre emma
contre marine le pen a été une autoroute
une course à l'échalote face aux idées
de madame le pen et du rassemblement
national d'ailleurs elles votent souvent
en accord avec les lois proposées par la
majorité présidentielle en disant
qu'elle n'aurait pas fait mieux
et rappelez-vous le ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin face à elle
sur un plateau de télévision qui la
trouvaient trop molle donc c'est vous
dire que oui emmanuel macron est loin
d'être un rempart face à marine le pen
dont les idées sont devenus quasiment
majoritaire au sein de la société
française si on en croit les médias qui
jour après jour vont resservir à peu
près les mêmes débats sur l'islamophobie
sur le voile sur le séparatisme sur
plein d'autres choses mais quand on
creuse un peu madame le pen est tout à
fait raccord également avec emmanuel
macron sur la politique européenne
elle est devenue finalement pro europe
elle est devenue également chantre de la
dette en disant qu'il faudra de toute
façon rembourse la dette
et puis elle est en train de revenir et
à droite après avoir essayé de draguer
les classes populaires en disant qu'elle
était anti système
elle est tout à fait partie prenante du
système certains disent même d'elle
qu'elle est l'autre face de la pièce est
mal macron d'un côté et marine le pen de
l'autre pour assurer une politique qui
sera toujours celle finalement des
objectifs de l'union européenne avec des
minima sociaux toujours moindre avec
davantage de compétition économique avec
toujours moins de souveraineté pour la
nation française donc oui je ne vois pas
en quoi finalement elle se distingue
beaucoup d' emmanuel macron peut-être un
peu plus de passes et de xénophobie un
peu plus de populisme entre guillemets
mais on a bien du mal dans les
programmes et on attend d'ailleurs les
programmes de madame le pen en matière
économique et autres évidemment
départager ces deux là si ce n'est
qu'ils aimeraient le maquereau a donné
une image un peu plus moderne un peu
plus progressistes comme il aimait à le
dire sur les sujets sociétaux que ce
soit l'euthanasie que ce soit le mariage
pour tous et c'est là où madame le pen
sera plus classique et aujourd'hui on
voit bien qu'elle va essayé de draguer
l'électorat de droite en disant que la
seule candidate crédible à droite c'est
elle alors en tout cas il va plus loin
en amont de bons parce que lui il dit
carrément que c'est la faute à maquereau
que c'est emmanuel macron qui mettra
madame le pen au pouvoir dit il
il compare d'ailleurs cela aussi au
phénomène trump ou au phénomène du bric
site de naujac et vous qui avez vécu
plusieurs années avec connaissez bien
les états unis est ce que c'est
réellement comparables à ce phénomène
trump ce qui peut se passer en 2022 et
ce qui va se passer carrément selon
arnaud montebourg en fait on a toujours
eu que tu me dire qu on irait vers
marine le pen le jour où on aurait tout
essayé et que les français ont le
sentiment de vraiment tout essayé
jusqu'à la dernière minute d'écart yvan
dans le vide
se disant que tant qu'à sauter autant
sauter avec un nouveau parachute en
attendent puisqu'on considère que les
autres son sang sont plus capable
d'amortir votre chute donc comparable
aux états unis à un ou deux regards oui
le premier c'est que trump a su est un
des premiers présidents a parlé à une
amérique qui sentait oublier enfin
parler une amérique qui sont est
déclassé a aussi une population blanche
on l'a vu un qui santé has et déclassé
pas forcément vis-à-vis des noirs
américains s'étaient pas trop le cas un
éventuellement des hispaniques mais
surtout il y avait un watch hington et
il ya le reste de la population et tout
à coup il a su leur parler avec des mots
simples et leur dire je vais vous faire
remonter au créneau vous allez remonter
l'échelle sociale c'était le rêve
américain et je vais vous le rendre je
suis pas sûr que avec un discours très
business très argent on va créer des
jobs et c'était quand même son sa
promesse principale pour l'instant et
monsieur rappeler à vendre comme on n'a
jamais vraiment bien compris le le
programme économique de marine le pen
qui flirtait quand même plus du côté
gauche que du côté droit là elle s'est
entourée de nouveaux collaborateurs qui
vont peut-être arriver avec des idées un
peu nouvelle plus progressistes etc
mais c'était quand même avant une
extrême droite avec un programme de
gauche couronne en gros donc du coup
c'est assez difficile mais par contre ce
qui est clair c'est qu'aujourd'hui il
faut bien comprendre une chose sexuelle
est déjà à 48 % dans les sondages
un moment donné on n'a pas encore les
vrais effets de la récession qui vont
arriver dans quelques semaines et dans
quelques mois
c'est là on va vraiment savoir si marine
le pen est une chance de gagner sierre
si on rentre vraiment et que les
français sortent de leurs anesthésie
qu'ils réalisent que finalement pour
relativement peu et je le dis en toute
conscience pour relativement peu et
notamment ce moment pour quatre ou cinq
mille personnes dans un lit de
réanimation
on a bloqué un pays de 68 millions
d'habitants il ya un moment donné ils
vont se poser la question de savoir
pourquoi ils ont perdu leur job
pourquoi ils ont perdu leur entreprise
pourquoi ils ont perdu leur jeunesse
et quand vous voyez aux etats-unis comme
en france que les taux de suicide et les
taux de dépression lourdes franchissent
des bons de 25 ou 28 %
ben il faut pas s'étonner que si les
jeunes montent au créneau demain on sait
selon ipsos et d'autre que au delà de 25
ans ils votent principalement au
rassemblement national donc je pense
qu'elle a vraiment des chances de gagner
oui comme arnaud que je connais bien par
ailleurs et avec quel sens de la formule
beaucoup plus que moi mais c'est vrai
que l a des chances parce que si elle
est déjà 48 dans les intentions
aujourd'hui demain quand la récession va
vraiment montré son vrai visage
elle risque de faire un bond assez
spectaculaire non mais des tice est
intéressant c'est quelques notions les
oublier la population blanche alors
c'est vrai qu'il ya une différence
notoire
voilà la même culture au niveau
économique mais ça nous rappelle quelque
chose ici en france la crise des gilets
jaunes effectivement la récession qui
peut arriver
la perte des emplois c'est ça il
pourrait faire gagner marine le pen et
en ce sens c'est emmanuel macron qui en
sort est le responsable
tout simplement parce que si vous voulez
faire s'il ya aujourd'hui des classes
populaires et des classes moyennes qui
ne se retrouvent plus dans les offres
politiques classiques
emmanuel macron avait réussi en 2017 à
incarner une forme de dégagisme mais le
problème c'est que le dégât lyrisme qui
l'incarné n'était finalement qu'une
bouée de sauvetage pour des offres
politiques qui ne parvenait plus à
performer dans l'électorat et ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui c'est que on voit bien
que la marque le pen qui est en train de
se recentrer manifestement elle fait un
gros travail de communication politique
pour essayer de polir les aspects qui
étaient les plus allergiques dans son
image
marine le pen est en train actuellement
on le voit de modifier son discours
économique e tour finalement essayé de
complaire à une clientèle politique à
droite qui partager
un certain nombre de ses convictions sur
des sujets qui étaient les sujets
sociétaux
mais qui disons et mettez un certain
nombre de doutes sur son programme
économique
on considère d'ailleurs qu'en 2017 elle
a aussi vraisemblablement connu un échec
en raison de ses propositions
économiques qui pouvaient affolé une
partie de cet électorat donc marine le
pen aujourd'hui est en train de créer
des conditions de son éligibilité et
elle n'était pas considérée comme
éligible en 2017
elle est aujourd'hui considérée comme
potentiellement éligibles et les
sondages le démontrent parce que les
sondages qui se réitère depuis
maintenant un certain nombre de semaines
montrent que emmanuel macron qui avait
fait finalement de sa candidature
le barrage au populisme et perd elle se
retrouve dans une marge d'incertitude au
second tour que les sondages
alain traduisent donc ne serait ce que
la publication de ces sondages finissent
par crédibiliser la candidature est là
le potentiel de victoire de marine le
pen
donc ça c'est le premier le premier
essai le deuxième aspect c'est que de
toute façon aujourd'hui il existe une
demande de rupture par rapport à encore
une fois des forces politiques dont on
considère que alternance par alternance
elles ont échoué et marine le pen tout
en se recentrant conserve quand même une
caractéristique majeure de sa marque
c'est le côté qui est certes encore un
peu sulfureux mais qui semble attester
pour une partie de l'opinion qu'elle est
en mesure d'assurer cette rupture
donc elle a une communication politique
qui est assez efficace de ce point de
vue et qui peut la mettre en bonne
position
en tout cas pour battre emmanuel macron
en tout cas l'intérêt manifeste de se
retrouver face à emmanuel macron parce
que vraisemblablement peut-être qu
emmanuel macron est le plus mauvais
candidat aujourd'hui pour faire barrage
à marine le pen en l'occurrence est ce
qui peut se passer quand même parce
qu'on est quand même très loin de
l'élection encore un an c'est énorme et
l'histoire électorale nous démontre que
toutes les projections qui ont été
faites depuis des années des années se
sont trouvés
infirmée par les faits si on suivait les
sondages monsieur balladur était et luxe
en 1994 il ne passe pas le premier tour
de l'élection
si on suivait les sondages monsieur
jospin avait de bonnes chances d'être
élu il ne passe pas le premier tour de
l'élection si l'on suivait les sondages
monsieur fillon en novembre 2016 été élu
à la présidence de la république et on
sait ce qu'il en a été
donc il faut être quand même toujours
très prudent mais quand même force est
de constater que aujourd'hui marine le
pen a une capacité à pouvoir agréger
autour d'elle un certain nombre de
mécontentement et de franchir le barrage
et emmanuel ma comprend en effet un
risque considérable on faisant des
choses s'améliorent opposant justement
vous disiez ils ont intérêt à se
retrouver l'un en face de l'autre ces
deux là alors justement à l'extrême
gauche et à l'ego d'ailleurs ça plaît
pas du tout à fait sorti d'arnaud
montebourg les soutiens de candidats il
candidat mélenchon n'ont pas trop
apprécié regardez ce commentaire du chef
de file de la france a soumis son
département de seine-saint-denis
justement arnaud montebourg a raison sur
emmanuel macron mais totalement tort
d'ignorer que la seule candidature
capable d'être un rempart à le pen et
macron resto jean luc mélenchon
l'ignorer et se rendre complice de la
macro ni ce qui n'est pas normalement
son credo à l'excès pour justement
arnaud benedetti nous parler de deux
populismes
ce qui fait du populisme emmanuel macron
où il joue justement cette carte de la
division à l'exemple même ici à gauche
et il va y avoir un duel entre jean luc
mélenchon et arnaud montebourg
de toute façon la gauche est divisée
on voit bien les tentatives d'avoir une
candidature unique lancée par yannick
jadot d'europe écologie les verts sont
loin d'avoir abouti il ça discute de
tout les côtés mais on est loin d'avoir
et un candidat et un programme commun
jean luc mélenchon lui un programme il
est candidat c'est le seul déclaré et il
compte bien y aller il ya sandrine
rousseau également du côté des dévers
donc il n'a même pas besoin de diviser
la gauche ni diviser la droite ces deux
grands partis historiques sont de toute
façon divisé et depuis longtemps
la question qui se pose c'est est-ce que
emmanuel macron a fait du populisme
oui emmanuel macron c'est un trump à la
sauce française
c'est quelqu'un qui a été capable de
créer une réalité alternative écouter
ses ministres
comme jean michel blanquer qui sortent
mensonge après mensonge pour se
justifier de ratage de leur
administration
ça c'est typiquement entretien le
rapport avec les médias la façon dont
les mollets matheron a toujours traité
les médias de manière assez hautaine et
suspicieuse en disant que nous étions
défectueuse que nous étions ceux qui
étaient là pour montrer la face cachée
finalement de ce qu'il veut faire
puisqu'il est entièrement sur la
communication et communicationnel moins
bien sûr que donald trump venait de la
télé réalité qui avaient tous les codes
mais néanmoins on voit bien que c'est me
marchand qui a poussé cette candidature
c'est l'image qui est au coeur
finalement du système
ma chronique élevé le maquereau nisme
c'est un populisme des élites c'est à
peu près la même recette un chef pas
vraiment de programme et et l'idée qu'
on a toujours raison et que les autres
ont tort voilà la réalité aujourd'hui je
suis d'accord avec arnaud benedetti
c'est un des rares candidats extrêmement
faibles s'il est question de faire
barrage à marine le pen
c'est sans doute le plus mauvais des
candidats effectivement à mettre en face
de madame le pen en 2022
pour éviter que madame le pen ne puisse
gagner
elle n'a rien à faire elle n'a qu'à
regarder et écouter se taire le plus
longtemps possible avant que de prendre
la parole et de voir qui va se rallier à
sa candidature car la question qui va se
poser maintenant c est ce que marine le
pen peut agréger sortir du cadre
classique du rassemblement national et
devenir ce qu'elle rêve c'est-à-dire la
candidate finalement officielle d'une
droite recomposée autour d'elle alors en
tout cas on dit souvent que c'est la
colère un tripot seraient les français à
voter marine le pen je voudrais qu'on
regarde tout simplement des chiffres 1
denis jacquet faisait référence tout à
l'heure ce sont les chiffres du chômage
en france sur fond de pandémie sur un an
6 millions qu'elle 142 1880 français au
chômage en février 2020 un an plus tard
c'est à peu près 442000 de plus c'est
absolument ça qu'il faut régler ça va
être compliqué d'ici à 2022 on imagine
denis jacquet vous savez beau pour
reprendre la comparaison avec les états
unis ce qu'il pouvait faire gagner
joe biden dans cette élection parce que
franchement trump est pas passé si loin
et d'ailleurs je confirme ce que disait
monsieur tout à l'heure sur les sondages
tout le monde l'annoncé ratiboiser et ça
a été très très loin de ça donc il faut
se méfier jusqu'à la dernière mine
mais il ya plusieurs choses 1 on n'a pas
encore il les conséquences de la crise
économique qui est qui reste sous
jacente anesthésié sous le tapis parce
que les subventions les prêts les
reports de charges enfin tout dispositif
qui était d'ailleurs indispensable qui a
été mis en place
reste néanmoins une espèce de grosse
masse de poussière sous le tapis à un
moment donné le tapis qui va soulever
donc je vous rappelle que c'est quand
même pratiquement huit cent mille
chômeurs de plus en espagne qui a aucune
espèce de chances qu'on fasse mieux en
france donc pour l'instant les
liquidations sont reportés les
redressements judiciaires sont
temporiser et le chômage fruits sous le
l'aspect du chômage partiel donc quand
tout ça va se dévoiler
moi la grande question c'est soit
emmanuel macron a envie de gagner à tout
prix et il va lâcher les vannes ouvrir
le robinet du crédit des aides jusqu'à
l'élection pour s'offrir l'élection avec
de la dette
ça me parait c'est difficile à hâter
encore pendant un an cinq ou six mois il
pourrait tenir mais un an c'est beaucoup
trop loin de ce que ses partenaires
européens certains d'entre eux vont ou
un peu sonné la fin de la partie
et la deuxième chose aux etats-unis
c'était plutôt la population noire
américaine qui pouvait décider de
l'élection ce qui s'est passé chez nous
cette fois c'est les jeunes qui
d'habitude votent pas ou peu et là on
sait que alors un peu moins les 18 22
mai au delà de 24 25
si les jeunes sortent cette fois ils
vont ils vont voter massivement au front
national ils peuvent faire basculer les
choses et en même temps il peut y avoir
aussi une surprise d'ailleurs celle d'un
edouard philippe et cetera qui lui a
peut-être encore une crédibilité pour
aller chercher un un électorat au centre
alors qu'aujourd'hui
macron a totalement perdu son aile
gauche de celle qui pourtant l'a aidé à
venir au pouvoir tous ses soutiens
colons et c était quand même plutôt des
gens de gauche à droite bat bien
évidemment il ya enfin des candidats qui
se manifeste donc en fait avoir des
candidats à droite
et puis il voulait aller mordre sur
l'extrême droite on l'a vu ces derniers
mois avec différents débats qu'il a
lancée mais les gens c'est comme le
canada dry à un moment donné ils
préfèrent l'original que la copie donc
du coup il n'a pas de réserve ni à
droite ni à gauche une situation
économique qui va revenir comme un
tsunami inversée qui va lui retomber
dessus d'ici l'année prochaine
et si les conséquences sont celles que
je pense en tout cas il ne serait ce que
pour les entreprises on voir le double
du taux de faillite de tous nos voisins
européens on risque d'avoir
effectivement un cataclysme et le qui
l'emportera moi je vois même des
scénarios on se retrouve avec un écolo
et marine le pen au second tour ça ne
paraît pas totalement invraisemblable et
ça promet effectivement peut-être de
grandes surprises encore merci pour ces
analyse passionnante messieurs arnaud
benedetti denis jacquet et alexis
poulain merci à vous d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france restez avec
nous dans quelques instants nous
parlerons du rapport annuel d'amnesty
international carton rouge pour la
france selon angie pointe l'engagement
du pays dans une voie nocifs pour les
droits humains
et puis direction les états unis un mot
d'ordre la balle avec six nations pour
tous joe biden place la barre encore un
peu plus haut à partir du 19 avril tous
les adultes devraient pouvoir recevoir
l'injection anticorrida
[Musique]
la gauche aujourd'hui et surtout faible
parce qu'elle a déçu parce qu'elle n'a
pas répondu aux attentes et aux espoirs
qui étaient placés en elle pour vous
c'est quoi finalement
l'enjeu principal les législatives où la
présidentielle nous souhaitons parler
avant tout à toutes celles et ceux qui
n'y croient plus qu'ils s'abstiennent
aujourd'hui vous voyez il ya énormément
de français aujourd'hui qu'ils ne
veulent plus aller voter puisque vous
parlez de ce nouveau souffle à gauche
cela s'inscrit dans un rassemblement on
a du mal à comprendre l'idée d'une
candidature communiste je ne souhaite
pas que dès maintenant pour new deal et
bien vous n'avez pas le droit de
présenter votre candidature de quel
droit aujourd'hui on pourrait dire ça
laissez les français décider oui le
parti communiste français soit de
pouvoir incarner l'alternative le
changement l'espoir
vous
tout
l'agité pour tous ce que ça apporte aux
enfants c'est une confiance confiance en
soi ils ont soif d'apprendre et izm la
connaissance mais quelque chose les
blocs aussi dans l'apprentissage à
l'école les enfants de l'ambition ils
veulent à accéder à des groupes veulent
s'évader du quartier qu'est ce qui ne
fonctionne pas dans l'apprentissage à
l'école les professeurs des écoles fonds
nécessaires mais je rencontre des
instituteurs des institutrices en ce1
ce2 il ya des enfants qui ont vraiment
encore du mal à lire et écrire
et c'est pénalisant pour l'enfant pour
la famille on oublie les parents qui
sont responsables du foyer est temps que
les parents ne maîtrise et ne parlent
pas le français à la maison basse année
difficile
[Musique]
les trente ans que les cours sont
manipulés comment est-ce qu'on peut
réguler ça on ne peut pas c'est une
manipulation on va dire 2-0 civilité de
cette manipulation est encore plus
facile parce que vous avez de nouveaux
traders parce que vous avez des gens qui
ont été attirés par de l'argent assez
facile le bitcoin illustre quelque chose
qui existe de toute éternité gagner de
l'argent en ne faisant rien en achetant
un actif qui nous vaut intrinsèquement
rien grâce à des gogos qui n'y
comprennent rien sauf la promesse de
faire fortune qui en profitent
réellement de ces manipulations pour
malheureusement c'est pas les petites
sardines c'est des requins que le petit
particulier il est là pour se faire
prendre
[Musique]
20h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france si vous nous rejoignez carton
rouge pour la france une sanction
adressée par la secrétaire générale
d'amnesty international agnès callamard
selon elle
l'hexagone s'est engagé dans une voie
nocifs pour les droits humains dans son
rapport annuel ong évoquent un usage
excessif de la force des droits des
migrants bafoués ou encore des ventes
d'armes irresponsable dieu m'a aussi le
moins que l'on puisse dire c'est que le
tableau de la france brossé par amnesty
international et sa secrétaire général
n'a rien de flatteur
les manquements aux droits de l'homme
pointé dans le rapport de l' ong paru ce
mercredi sont nombreux à commencer par
le recours excessif à la force
amnesty international évoque par exemple
la mort de cédric joue via en janvier
2020 le maintien de l'emploi de la
technique de l'étranglement ainsi que le
port d'armes dangereuses ou encore le
peu d'entrain affiché par la france à
poursuivre les auteurs de violences
policières
il n'y avait toujours pas de mécanisme
indépendant chargé d'enquêter sur les
cas d'utilisation illégale de la force
très peu de membres des forces de
l'ordre ont fait l'objet de poursuites
judiciaires à la suite des allégations
d'usagé excessif de la force
pendant les manifestations de 2018 et
2019 des violences policières toujours
impunis et que la loi de sécurité
globale rendrait encore plus compliqué à
sanctionner si on en croit la patronne
d'amnesty international la loi de
sécurité globale à renforcer le pouvoir
des forces de l'ordre à imposer une
forme de surveillance a contraint les
témoins les citoyens à être beaucoup
plus sur leurs gardes
quand ils ont quand ils sont les témoins
de violences policières plus
généralement le rapport note un recul de
certaines libertés liberté de se réunir
avec une interdiction générale de
manifester imposée temporairement par le
gouvernement en mai dernier recul de la
liberté d'expression également avec la
poursuite de nombreuses personnes
pour outrage à agents ou apologie du
terrorisme des infractions jugées trop
vague par les ong mais amnesty
s'inquiète surtout en ces temps de
covile d'un recul de l'état de droit
avec les mesures d'exception imposer un
peu partout à travers la planète et
notamment en france
ce que le coc vide a permis c'est une
normalisation des mesures d'urgence où
on d état d'urgence donc les phénomènes
de surveillance les pouvoirs accrus à la
police
la grande frayeur la grande inquiétude
d'amnesty international c'est de voir ce
projet ce que nous avons déjà vu au nom
du contre terrorisme c'est à dire la
normalisation des mesures
exceptionnelles et amnesty n'est pas la
seule à s'inquiéter de ces dérives même
des députés de la majorité ont tenu en
février dernier a alerté le premier
ministre sur je cite l'extension quasi
illimitée des prérogatives de la
puissance publique et la réduction
drastique des libertés fondamentales
outre les reculs de ses libertés on peut
aussi relever dans ce rapport la vente
d'armes irresponsable notamment révélé
par le média d'investigation disclose en
2019 le gouvernement a continué de
vendre des armes à l'arabie saoudite et
aux émirats arabes unis malgré la forte
probabilité qu'elle soit utilisée pour
commettre des violations des droits
humains dans le cadre du conflit au
yémen
nous vendons des armes à des états qui
sont reconnus comme responsables de
crimes de guerre de crimes contre
l'humanité et cetera et pour clore cet
éloge on peut enfin citer en vrac le
non-respect du droit d'asile et des
droits des migrants
le manque de moyens déployés par l'état
face à l'urgence climatique le racisme
de certains membres des forces de
l'ordre ou les grandes entreprises
françaises qui sont encore trop
nombreuses à ne pas se soucier du
respect des droits humains par leurs
sous traitants
n'en jetez plus la coupe est pleine et
donc face à tous ces manquements la
secrétaire générale d'amnesty
international tire la sonnette d'alarmé
quand on s'engage dans une politique qui
remet en cause ses droits nous nous
engageons dans une politique la france
s'engage dans une politique extrêmement
nocive pour l'ensemble des droits
humains un comble pour la patrie
supposées des droits de l'homme 1 et
pour en parler nous sommes avec evelyne
sire-marin magistrate mans de la ligue
des droits de l'homme bonsoir madame se
faire mal un merci d'être avec nous on
viens de l'entendre amnesty qui dénonce
des développements qui vont dans une
direction nocifs problématiques et
dangereuses on parle tout de même de la
france le pays des droits de l'homme à
ce que vous partagez vous ce sentiment
oui je partage ce sentiment je ne suis
pas la seule il y a également le
rapporteur spécial de l'onu qui a
souligné qu' il y avait une régression
des droits de l'état de droit en france
et aussi la cncdh la commission
nationale pour les droits de l'homme
donc c'est un problème en ce sens que la
france est engagée sur un terrain de
diminution des droits des citoyens
depuis un temps assez long depuis vingt
ou trente ans il ya eu trente et une loi
sécuritaire depuis une trentaine
d'années et ces dernières années huit
lois qui ont augmenté les pouvoirs de la
police diminuent et les compétences des
juges indépendants en france
est ce qu'on observe aussi et ce qui n'a
peut-être pas été dit c'est que
peut-être une limitation du rôle du
parlement c'est une démocratie la
démocratie française où l'exécutif a de
plus en plus de poids le judiciaire
bien qu'il ya des affaires médiatiques
qui semble indiquer que notamment en
matière économique et financière la
justice joue tout à fait son rôle
désormais mais en même temps il y a
comme le disait montesquieu une
incapacité pour les pouvoirs judiciaires
et pour le parlement d'arrêter le
pouvoir exécutif
quand est ce que disait le pouvoir doit
arrêter le pouvoir
c'est ça il va y avoir des
contre-pouvoirs dans une démocratie et
là ce qu'on observe pardon c'est
notamment avec l'état d'urgence lé
l'état d'urgence sanitaire et avant
antiterroriste depuis cinq ans on
vraiment libère limitée beaucoup les
libertés individuelles
juste des peurs justement madame c'était
ma question suivante à quoi attribues
ton ces dérives un dénoncée par amnesty
cette crise du duc au vip qui était
peut-être l'occasion pour les
gouvernements de serrer la vis ou wayne
une vraie volonté politique de le faire
c'était manifeste ou pas tant que ça
finalement bien écouter ce qui s'est
passé c'est que en fait le lan la
volonté n'a pas été uniquement de ce
gouvernement
il y a eu déjà avant beaucoup de lois
antiterroristes et ce qui s'est passé
aussi c'est bien sûr les attentats
absolument gravissime du bataclan de
charlie hebdo
donc il y a eu effectivement une
nécessité de lutter contre le terrorisme
mais est-ce que les moyens qui ont été
choisis étaient les bons moyens
je crois qu amnesty international pense
que non et la ligue des droits de
l'homme c'est exactement la même chose
c'est-à-dire que vous voyez on a permis
beaucoup plus les perquisitions au
domicile et fort des préfets notamment
la limitation du droit de manifester la
limitation également du droit de se
déplacer
le fait de pouvoir assigner à résidence
des personnes par non pas par des juges
eux mais par des préfets des autorités
exécutives
voilà je crois que les moyens qui ont
été choisis n'était pas n'étaient pas
les bons parce que ça a permis aussi
finalement de réprimer le mouvement
social il faut bien le dire mais gilet
jaune et c'est donc
et là on assiste en ce moment à deux
lois qui pose énormément de problèmes
la loi sécurité globale qui s'appelle
autrement désormais qui est en
commission mixte paritaire et qui crée
une nouvelle infraction à troyes ce soir
elle est dangereuse oui elle est drôle
chose pour la liberté
la presse et pour la liberté
d'expression en ce sens que ça va être
maintenant le fait de divulguer des
éléments d'identification d'un militaire
d'un policier qui va être puni de cinq
ans d'emprisonnement
or vous savez qu'il ya eu des violences
policières en france c'est certain même
si de façon générale la police fait son
travail il ya eu des violences
policières et devant la justice le fait
de filmer des violences policières qui
se déroule
c'est la seule manière d'obtenir des
preuves pour établir ces violences
policières et punir les auteurs
donc je trouve que les pénaliser
pénalité les gens qui filme ces
violences policières c'est un problème
la france qui est également épinglé un
an sa gestion de des enfants de
djihadistes retenues dans les camps en
syrie on rappelle quand même une notion
c'est aussi l'opinion publique
est-ce que l'exécutif est pris en étau
justement par ses opinions et qui
demandent peut-être de de la fermeté sur
ce genre de thématique bien sûr il faut
quand même souligner aussi que la france
dans le conseil de l'europe n'est pas le
pire pays un bien sûr de déclin des
droits
on a quand même d'autres pays bien
évidemment qu'ils sont bien pire puisque
je pense à la turquie je pense à la
russie notamment où là on a carrément le
fait d'emprisonner ou d'essayer même de
d'éliminer des opposants politiques mais
la france vous avez raison et prise un
peu en étau entre une opinion publique
d'hôtes ont dit qu elle voudrait plus de
répression et en même temps vous savez
quand vous parlez avec les gens on
s'aperçoit que quand cette répression
touche des proches
easy sont absolument opposés je pense
notamment à la question des violences
policières vous m'interrogez sur les
enfants de djihadistes je crois que de
nombreux français peuvent admettre que
un enfant qu'à 35 ans enfermé dans un
camp n'est pas un terroriste et qu'il
serait très souhaitable de le rapatrier
en france
autre épingla de la france à son rôle
dans l'exportation des armes paris qui
se place comme l'un des plus importants
exportateurs d'armes dans le monde
parfois vers des pays qui ne respectent
pas justement les les droits de l'homme
doit-on également de changer politique
sur ce sujet on est d'ailleurs assez en
retard par rapport à certains voisins
européens comme l'allemagne ou l'italie
bien sûr on est en retard aussi du poilu
judiciaire puisque il y aura eu des
condamnations a notamment d'affaires de
corruption et ses alliés à l'exportation
des armes il lié à la vente d'armes mais
la france est tout à fait en retard et
je crois que là-dessus investi
international a beaucoup travaillé sur
ces questions fait des propositions et
il serait tout à fait souhaitable que il
ya des conditions qui soient mises
notamment au commerce
en ce qui concerne les pays qui violent
systématiquement les droits de l'homme
il serait vraiment souhaitable que la
france arrête de leur vendre des armes
et autres questions abordées par nestier
à la question des migrants en france
il faut également changer
les lois là aussi l'opinion publique et
un poids oui alors on pourra que par
exemple dans les écoles
souvent les parents d'élèves sont
extrêmement sensibles au sort des
enfants étrangers
les enfants m'aiment de personnes qui
sont sans papiers est souvent les
parents d'élèves ont un mouvement
vraiment de grande humanité en se disant
mais ces enfants ont le droit d'aller à
l'école comme tout le monde
par ailleurs vous savez que la
législation s'agissant de l'immigration
s'est durcie ya énormément depuis vingt
ans notamment par exemple séjour en
centre de rétention est de plus en plus
long lorsque les gens n'ont pas de
papiers la france essaye d'expulser les
personnes lorsqu'elles ont commis
évidemment des actes contraires à
l'ordre au public ce qu'on ne dit pas
assez c'est que c'est extrêmement
difficile puisque beaucoup de ces
personnes lorsqu'elles sont délinquante
et c'est absolument pas du tout le cas
de l'immense majorité des étrangers mais
lorsqu'elles ont commis des actes
délinquants
il est très difficile en fait de les
expulser puisque souvent elles ont
déchiré leur part leur passeport leur
pièce d'identité et donc on ne peut pas
en fait les expulser dans leur pays
d'origine et souvent ne connaît même pas
leur pays d'origine mais c'est vraiment
une toute petite minorité par rapport à
l'extrême majorité des gens qui sont
étrangers en france et il semble que il
serait souhaitable quand même de
permettre beaucoup plus facilement la
naturalisation de personnes qui
souhaitent s'intégrer sur le territoire
français quant à la condition des
étrangers elle est quand même
extrêmement difficile en france lorsque
ils veulent être régularisés merci vince
terme à rien d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france
elle lutte contre la pandémie dans le
monde plusieurs pays ont mis en place on
envisage d'instaurer un passeport
vaccinale aux états unis où la campagne
de vaccination ne cesse de s'accélérer
la question est sur la table mais l'idée
de passeports sanitaire ne séduit pas
tout le monde est là medjahed
je suis heureux c'est génial qu'à new
york vous puissiez obtenir votre vaccin
pour les plus jeunes
donc je viens de recevoir ma première
dose maintenant comme harry un américain
sur trois a reçu au moins une dose un
vaccin contre le coc vie 19 et les etats
unis comptent bien donner un nouveau
coup d'accélérateur à leur campagne de
vaccination tous les adultes seront
éligibles pour en bénéficier d'ici au 19
avril prochain dans le pays
une campagne de vaccination qui
s'accompagne d'une polémique autour de
la mise en place ou non d'un passeport
qu'ovide numérique
new york est pour l'instant le seul des
états américains vont lancer un tel
passe sur la base du volontariat un code
qr sur smartphone qui certifie qu une
personne est immunisé contre le courant
n'a virus d'autres gouverneurs s'y
opposent fermement
au nom des libertés individuelles c'est
totalement inacceptable qu'un
gouvernement que le secteur privé vous
impose de montrer une preuve de
vaccination simplement pour participer à
la société
vous voulez aller au cinéma est-ce que
vous devrez montrer ça non vous voulez
aller voir un match non vous voulez
aller dans un parc d'attractions non
nous ne sommes pas d'accord avec ça des
mots suivis d'actes s'est très
rapidement
le gouverneur de floride a signé un
décret vendredi dernier interdisant aux
services administratifs de son état de
délivrer tout passeport vaccinale
quelques jours plus tard c'est au tour
de son homologue républicain du texas
d'interdire une série d'organismes
d'exiger des preuves de vaccination et
face à la controverse politique
le gouvernement des états unis lui
affirme être toujours contre ce
passeport national le gouvernement ne
soutien pas et ne soutiendra pas un
système qui demanderait aux américains
d'avoir un certificat
il n'y aura pas de bases de données
fédérale sur les vaccinations ni
d'obligations fédérales exigent à tous
d'obtenir un certificat de vaccination
et données personnelles et les droits
des américains doivent être
protéger et donc ces systèmes ne doivent
pas être utilisés contre les gens de
façon injuste l'idée d'un passeport
sanitaires fédérales est donc écartée
pour le moment aux états unis la maison
blanche laisse cependant le secteur
privé libre d'avancer vers cette option
et ce malgré les inquiétudes
grandissantes sur de possibles
discriminations et la protection des
données privées
pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis washington avec tristan kabelo au
maître de conférences en civilisation
américaine spécialiste de l'histoire
afro-américaine
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soir bonsoir christ en kabylie merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
aux états unis la vaccination est en
pleine effervescence ans se réjouit le
président baydan annonçant qu'à partir
du 19 avril tous les adultes américains
seraient éligibles à la vaccination les
états unis commencent à réellement voir
le bout du tunnel
oui vous avez tout à fait raison on voit
vraiment le bout du tunnel ici il faut
savoir que tout le monde s'y est mis un
les pharmacies les médecins généralistes
les hôpitaux les employeurs on pouvait
vraiment se faire vacciner à peu près
partout ici aux etats-unis et donc ce
que l'on voit c'est vraiment la fin du
tunnel la fin de cette de cette épidémie
beaucoup de maires ont déjà publié leurs
plans de réouverture pour leur bile la
mère de washington dc a publié son clan
de réouverture juste eu hier et dès la
mi mai il y aura donc les théâtres des
cinémas les salles de concerts qui
pourront réouvrir et puisque l'on voit
aussi c'est vraiment la vie de deux
mains vides après beaucoup d'entreprises
demandent maintenant à leurs employés
s'ils préféreraient travailler à plein
temps en distance yale puisque c'était
le cas durant la dernière année et donc
il ya beaucoup de choses qui se mettent
en place ici mais on voit vraiment la
fin du tunnel
alors effectivement un américain sur
trois qui a reçu au moins une dose de
vaccin la cannelle farnier qui rouvre le
15 juin
ce qui est intéressant ça sera de savoir
est ce que ces succès ils sont attribué
à joe biden qui a beaucoup communiqué
sur la crise sanitaire ou sur donald
trump qui a lui fortement misé sur le
vexin quitte à s'attirer les moqueries
parfois j'ai envie de dire ni l'un ni
l'autre un aux états unis
c'est ces entreprises se sont
complètement décentralisé c'est à dire
que le gouvernement fédéral finalement
avait très peu à voir avec la logistique
et l'organisation de la distribution des
vaccins et de la vaccination c'est
vraiment au niveau des états et au
niveau des villes au niveau des
employeurs que ce genre de choses a été
fait maintenant il est vrai que dans la
conscience populaire byden récolte un
peu les bons points de cette bonne
campagne de vaccination alors il ya une
polémique 1 sur la mise en place son nom
d'un passeport vaccinale ce que vous
pensez que cela pourrait être un nouveau
sujet de discorde entre démocrates et
républicains
alors nous sommes dans un pays ici où il
n'y a même pas de deux cartes d'identité
nationale en fait donc tout ce qui est
identique à sion au niveau fédéral est
complètement rejeté par les américains
mais il y a en fait ce
ce passeport vacciner en fête existe en
fait à peu près déjà puisqu'on nous
donne à chaque fois qu on est vacciné
une carte qui est sponsorisé par le sis
d'ici et le gouvernement fédéral qui
tend à prouver que nous sommes donc bien
vacciné je pense qu'il n'y aura jamais
de passeports vaccinale au niveau
fédéral par contre les employeurs et les
entreprises privées pourront demander la
preuve de cette vaccination
lorsque leurs employés viennent dans
leurs locaux les etats unis qui
disposent un an le sait de plusieurs
millions de doses d'astrazeneca qu'ils
ne peuvent pas utiliser n'ayant pas
donné l'autorisation d'utilisation mais
qui refuse pour autant d'en distribuer
notamment aux pays pauvres d'ailleurs
même à la france
ce choix de l'administration byden et
est-ce qu'ils aient compris trump ou
baden ça reste l'amérique aforst alors
ici on ne parle pas du tout de ce fameux
vaccin
astrazeneca puisque comme vous le dites
il n'a pas reçu l
la proue volant de la f10 y est mais les
trois autres vaccins moderna pfizer et
johnson & johnson sont très bien accepté
par la population est en fait dans tous
les centres de vaccination
on peut en fait choisir un casque vaccin
on veut avoir pour notre taxi nation ici
les américains ne parle pas beaucoup du
fait que hayden garde ses doses
d'astrazeneca
au cas où il y aurait des problèmes dans
la vaccination futur mais en tout cas by
donne tout comme trump vous l'avait bien
dit choisi america first est donc ces
doses d'astrazeneca resteront aux états
unis au cas où il y en aurait besoin un
jour ou l'autre
alors il ya une autre actualité un joe
raedle d'ailleurs après la parole il ya
quelques instants il juge un plan
d'investissements indispensables pour
que les états unis restent la première
puissance du monde s'étaient unies qui
financent donc ce plan d'investissement
en augmentant les impôts de leurs
sociétés de 21 à 28 %
cela rompt avec une politique de près de
40 années
n'est ce pas alors tout à fait j'ai même
envie de dire peut-être un siècle ces
dames il faut retourner au new deal pour
avoir un taux d'imposition si important
alors non seulement baden va augmenter
les impôts sur des entreprises dont de
24 à 28 % comme vous venez de dire mais
aussi il va augmenter les impôts sur les
revenus les plus hauts au dessus de 400
mille dollars par an il y aura un appeau
qui ressemblera un peu à un impôt sur la
fortune c'est très très surprenant de sa
part puisqu'il faut savoir qu'il avait
refusé le plan d'imposition d'elizabeth
warren qui voulait aussi un impôt sur la
fortune et qu'il a dit qu'il ne
n'augmenterait pas les impôts durant son
mandat
par contre il a aussi fait de grandes de
très grands projets ici un son prend de
son plan de sur l'infrastructure est
vraiment énormissime
il coûte très cher
jean de relance va coûter aussi très
cher est ce cette augmentation d'impôts
sur des entreprises est en trés acceptée
par les américains on voit qu'il y à une
campagne de communication qui est assez
bien rodée même des économistes de
droite de foxnews disent que c'est une
très bonne idée en fait pour la relance
du pays
effectivement c'est surprenant et dans
le même temps un joe biden qui veut
pousser ses partenaires internationaux
vers un accord sur un taux international
d'imposition minimal des entreprises
avant de vous faire réagir je vous
propose d'écouter la secrétaire d'état
au trésor américain
nous travaillons avec les pays du g20
pour s'entendre sur un taux minimal
d'imposition sur les entreprises
il pourrait mettre fin à la course vers
le bas ensemble nous pouvons utiliser
une taxation mondiale minent et mal sur
les entreprises pour nous assurer que
l'économie mondiale prospèrent sur la
base de règles du jeu plus équitables en
matière d'imposition des multinationales
et stimuler l'innovation la croissance
et la prospérité
alors c'est vrai que sur le papier on
n'attendait pas nécessairement les états
unis en pointe sur ce type de sujet oui
surtout on attendait pas du tout by
donne sur ce type de sujet de ce que
paris donne avait fait une campagne tout
à fait modéré qui rejetait vraiment la
gauche du parti démocrate
en dehors du parti démocrate et puis là
en plus ça vient de janet yellen
challenge et des n'advient vraiment
complètement du cera et 1 c'est une
vieille washingtonienne de
l'establishment qui n'a jamais eu
vraiment ce genre de positions avant
alors est-ce que encore une fois c'est
une entreprise de communication pour
baden qui essaye de rassembler son parti
démocrate principalement si la gauche et
les progressistes ou est ce que c'est
quelque chose qui va jusqu'au bout de ça
c'est assez difficile à savoir
vous vous rappelez qu'il y a quelques
mois au début du mandat il avait promis
des chèques de 2000 $
à tous les américains ces chèques ne
sont jamais arrivés ils ont eu 1600
dollars il avait promis aussi
l'université gratuite public de la santé
publique gratuite pour tous les
américains ça ne s'est pas passé donc
est ce que c'est encore une fois une
entreprise de communication ou est-ce
que ce plan en fait se dérouler jusqu'à
sa concrétisation je crois que les
quelques semaines qui arrivent là nous
le diront ea suivra donc merci tristan
cabello maître de conférences en
civilisation américaine spécialisée
l'histoire afro-américaine d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france rester
avec nous dans quelques instants nous
parlerons un nouveau duc au vide mais
cette fois son aspect médical avec la
question des séquelles selon une étude
le virus aurait de sérieux impacts sur
la santé mentale des patients allant de
l'anxiété sévère à la démence pour
certains et puis nous reviendrons sur la
polémique autour du projet de
construction de la mosquée de strasbourg
la préfète du bas rhin a décidé de
saisir la justice
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
c'est un coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la veille d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent là l on
soit vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui une gauche l'extrême musée
la ténacité tous les faits - de notre
époque sont dans la grande île interview
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la france a développé depuis la deuxième
guerre mondiale une capacité militaire
de défense et de projection elle est la
première puissance de l'union européenne
tant par le niveau d'investissement que
par la capacité opérationnelle
mais depuis dix ans pour rattraper son
retard
allemagne augmenter son budget deux fois
plus vite que la france nous avons
beaucoup de projets industriels et
capacités en commun mais il faut
reconnaître qu'en matière d'armement les
allemands ne sont pas des partenaires
très solide
il existe des divergences fondamentales
entre les ambitions militaires de la
france et celle de l'allemagne
à force de nous regarder avec
satisfaction
nous ne voyons pas ce qui se passe chez
nos voisins la france pourrait perdre
son leadership au sein de l'union
européenne dans le domaine de la défense
conventionnelle
dès cette année
[Musique]
en avril aura lieu le 60e anniversaire
du vol de youri gagarine en ayant eu la
chance de m'entraîner avec nos collègues
russes j'ai vraiment plongé dans une
atmosphère où j'ai vécu auprès de méroé
gagarine était présent à chaque au point
de bâtiments de salles de sport de place
de la cité des étoiles moi je crois
beaucoup dans la diplomatie scientifique
et quand vous parlez de la coopération
scientifique sur la station mir ou la
station spatiale internationale
c'est une forme de diplomatie on a très
peu d'objets aujourd'hui qui peuvent
être des outils diplomatiques aussi aux
six ans
[Musique]
gilet jaune au début ce n'était pas un
mouvement politique le peuple français
étaient arrivés ou de ce qu'ils
pouvaient supporter il ya énormément de
problèmes en france comment se fait-il
qu'on est les impôts les plus élevés
d'europe
comment se fait-il qu'on est les
déficits les plus importants
et comment se fait-il que nous dans les
campagnes on n'est même plus de service
public quand je vois l'état du pays
aujourd'hui
honnêtement j'ai mal au coeur c'est
justement tout le sens de la prochaine
élection présidentielle parce que c'est
là qu'il va falloir que les gens
apportent des réponses et moi je crois
que de toute façon on ne peut pas régler
les problèmes avec ceux qui les ont
créés c'est impossible
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
21h merci nous rejoindre pour cette
deuxième heure d'émission tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
mercredi 7 avril
le coc vide développe-t-il des séquelles
encore méconnu selon une étude
britannique une personne sur trois
remises ducobu 19 développe un troubles
neurologiques ou psychiatriques dans les
six mois suivant l'infection
côté vaccination l'agencé européenne du
médicament confiant pour la première
fois un lien entre le vaccin sera zeneca
et les cailloux sont bien mais précise
que c'est un phénomène très rare lieu
qui appelle les 27 à parler d'une seule
voix pour ne pas nourrir la défiance en
perse au sérum la mosquée de pantin
fermer en octobre après l'assassinât de
samuel pâtir ouvrira ce vendredi quant à
la mosquée de strasbourg la préfète du
bas-rhin décide de saisir la justice
afin d'annuler l'attribution d'une
subvention de deux millions et demi
d'euros à sa construction le financement
public du culte musulman la faveur de la
loi du concordat en plein débat sur la
loi séparatisme continue de faire réagir
délire poutine a reçu aujourd'hui à
moscou le premier ministre arménien
visite qui intervient dans un contexte
de crise politique en arménie pour en
sortir nikol pashinian annoncé sa
démission le chef du gouvernement kényan
décrié depuis la défaite militaire face
à l'azerbaïdjan dans le haut-karabagh le
président rwandais paul kagamé salue le
rapport sur le rôle de la france dans le
génocide de 1994 estimant qu'il marque
un important pas en avant vers une
compréhension commune de ce qu'il s'est
passé dans le même temps paris ouvre au
grand public des archives sur le sujet
plusieurs cérémonies étaient organisées
à paris et kigali en hommage aux
victimes du génocide au rwanda 27 ans
jour pour jour après
[Musique]
c'était un verdict attendu l'agencé
européenne du médicament suggère
d'ajouter des caillots sanguins sur la
liste des effets indésirables rare de
l'astra zeneca elle juge que ces
caillots devrait être ajouté à la liste
des effets secondaires très rare il
pourrait s'expliquer par une réponse
immunitaire la balance bénéfice risque
reste malgré tout positive de son côté
la belgique a déclaré réservé le vaccin
aux plus de 55 ans dans la foulée
l'union européenne appelle les
vingt-sept âge aussi de parler d'une
seule voix pour ne pas nourrir la
défiance oppose d'écouter la directrice
exécutive de l'agencé européenne des
médicaments
sur la base des résultats actuellement
disponibles des facteurs de risque
spécifiques tels que l'âge le sexe ou
les antécédents médicaux n'ont pas pu
être confirmées car les événements rares
sont observées à tous les âges aussi
bien chez les hommes que les femmes
caisse men and women une explication
plausible de ses effets secondaires
rares est une réponse immunitaire au
vaccin entraînant un état similaire à
celui observé chez les patients traités
à l'héparine cette dernière étude
britannique sur les séquelles du coc vie
de 19 à présent une personne sur trois
remises du virus développe un troubles
neurologiques ou psychiatriques
c'est la confusion publié dans 10
langues cette psychiatrie porte en plus
de supporter en se posant plus de 230
mille personnes 34 % d'entre eux ont
diagnostiqué un trouble neurologique ou
psychiatrique dans les fluides six mois
suivant l'infection parmi eux 17 % ont
développé des troubles de l'anxiété 14%
des troubles de l'humeur ou encore 5% de
l'insomnie et pour en parler nous sommes
avec philippe boutin médecins
généralistes bonsoir philippe boutin
merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france a dans cette étude
britannique évidemment assez froide ans
dans le dos ou est-ce que vous à votre
niveau vous l'avez constaté sur des
patients dans votre cabine et non sur
les conséquences dès qu ils l'ont bien
sûr avec immo rien et un certain nombre
de troupes qui sont encore méconnus mais
qui ont effectivement des connotations
neurologiques neuropsychiatriques et qui
sont assez durables avec des tableaux
qui sont assez impressionnants parfois
mais c'est un constant et enfin je vais
pas non plus enclins généralité
quand vous des tableaux assez
impressionnant on nous fait un petit
pétard ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que on a des tableaux dépressif
on a des tableaux qui manifeste qu'il a
atteintes neurologiques etc ces
importantes oui mais qui sont dans des
proportions assez assez rare aussi
pourquoi non plus généraliser on est sur
des colis de nom moi par exemple dans
mon maître entourage là une jeune femme
qui est en haut d'un état dépressif
important depuis maintenant cinq mois
alors docteur ça veut dire en gros on a
souvent entendu dans les effets sur les
poumons des effets notamment sur de la
fatigue mais ça ça veut dire clairement
quand on parle de dépression et c'est ce
que le cerveau a été touché le point de
départ et on sait depuis depuis
l'atteinte l'anoci à xi'an fabia
quand on a des troupes de l'odorat on a
déjà une atteinte neurologique niveau
cérébral qui est certes faible mais qui
un témoignage d'une appétence est aussi
possible pour les graisses aussi du
système nerveux des virus donc forcément
c'est une porte d'entrée et je veux pas
dire que tout il faut pas dire que tous
les gens qui ont des problèmes de le
smoothie on auprès des problèmes
dépressifs non mais ça veut dire qu'il
ya quand même une appétence du virus
vers les tissus neurologique oui ça se
joue sur deco vide
qui était grave ou même bénin ce genre
d'effets secondaires non on a pas de
corrélation alors bien sûr et des gens
qui ont fait des réanimations et qui
sont à juste titre très marquée par ces
périodes de réanimation mais il n'y a
pas forcément de corrélation entre des
manifestations allant thermique aux ide
et l'importance de ces munitions est-ce
qu'il faut clairement s'attendre à
d'autres effets encore méconnus de ce
virus on commence quand même à y voir un
petit peu claires dans les effets
secondaires alors les deux on y voit de
plus en plus clair c'est sûr mais il
faut s'attendre encore à des surprises
ce virus nous réservera
vraisemblablement encore pas mal de
surprises dans les prochains moins oui
or là je vais poser une question
volontairement provocatrice mais c'est
peut-être une question qu'on se pose ici
ou là les français et les autres
est ce qu'on nous dit on selon vous les
pouvoirs publics me disent tous ont pas
toujours forcément sur sur ce virus
on va sur le virus sur lui-même et
disent ce qu'ils savent et ont dit ce
que l'on sait on en dit est de trop même
puisque on parle sûrement de choses qui
ne sont pas encore stabilisés je pense
qu'il ya effectivement on est dans un
domaine qui qui qui recherchent en
permanence et c c'est ça qui est limite
passionnant dans cette pandémie
c'est qu'on en apprend tous les jours
donc bien évidemment moi je dire depuis
maintenant un an
on a des modifications de de thérapie de
protocoles deux fois par semaine voire
plus ce qui en fait quelque chose de non
stabilisé même pour les médecins donc
nous sommes nous sommes en permanence en
train d'apprendre est en train de
peaufiner notre stratégie est pour ces
patients atteints de ce col alors autre
actualité de la journée on vous l'avez
entendu astrazeneca l'agencé européenne
du médicament qui confirme que pour la
première fois il ya un lien entre ce
vaccin et des caillots sanguins mais qui
précise que c'est un phénomène très rare
on en média tout ça pour ça disent neuf
morts tout de même
au royaume uni en lien avec ce vaccin on
imagine que tout de même ça ne va pas
arranger la défiance envers lui vous
aurez pesait de plus en plus de mana
vaccinez vous les médecins avec ce sérum
alors d'abord cela sur la stratégie
vaccinale effectivement là pour nous que
ce soit avec un pharmacien et à fiable
et nous sommes dans la stratégie cas
cliniquement donc effectivement nous
prenons de plein fouet cette alors
d'abord les atermoiements de stratégie
vaccinale
au début ce vaccin était réservée au
moins de 65 ans maintenant il faut le
donner aux plus de 55 ans nouvelle et on
a changé du tout au tout donc c'est
quand même extrêmement et ça en l'espace
de quelques semaines on ne me d'une
semaine donc il faut il faut être au
contact des patients pour leur expliquer
les avantages de ceux de cette
vaccination par astra zeneca bon
maintenant que ce que je peux regretter
en tant que médecin c'est qu'on n'est
pas à disposition l'ensemble du panel
d'aidés des vaccins disponibles puisque
nous sommes parfaitement capables
maintenant d'avoir une dame voir des des
degrés de conservation pour le preiser
qui sont moins 15 - 20 donc qu'ils sont
parfaitement compatibles avec des
congélateurs médicaux normaux donc on
pourrait parfaitement rexie mais à
grande échelle avec les médecins
généralistes les médecins spécialistes
les pharmaciens et les infirmiers sur le
même rythme que ce que nous faisons pour
pour la grippe par exemple nous avons
fait plus de fautes 17 millions environ
au vaccin pour la grippe hanche
on est un peu plus de deux semaines je
pense que nous pourrions faire
exactement la même chose pour les
vaccins que vide et je pense que ce
serait autrement plus efficace que une
espèce de barnum qui donc sont mis en
place à grands frais avec les médias
présents j'avais venir justement qui
vous volent un peu la vedette à vous aux
médecins généralistes mais aussi aux
pharmaciens
clairement est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
avez assez de doses pour vacciner où
tout est un petit peu transférés dans
dance est un gros centre mais très
clairement depuis un mois et demi
en ce qui me concerne j'ai eu dix flacon
donc ça fait 100 doses que j'ai injecté
immédiatement je n'ai pas eu de deux
vaccins cette semaine j'en ai pas eues
la semaine dernière on en a promis pour
la fin de la semaine
j'en ai pu commander théoriquement le un
flacon lundi dernier donc voyez qu'on
est complètement à dose homéopathique
jour je vous je rappelle simplement à la
chine nous sommes cinquante cinq mille
généraliste qui nous avions un flacons
de dix doses par jour
nous serions un demi million de vaccinés
supplémentaire tous les jours le
problème c'est qu'il n'y a pas forcément
de doses en tout cas pas pour le moment
quand vous voyez que en allemagne la
bavière commandes précommande spoutnik
il ya d'autres pays de l'union
européenne qu'ils ont fait ça fait ch en
s'affranchissant petit peu des règles de
l'europe
est-ce que selon vous en tant que
médecin vous pensez que
la france doit s'y mettre également
parce qu apparemment d'après thierry
breton n'a n'aura pas vraiment besoin de
ça avec sa mèche je pense qu'il faut
faire avec les vaccins qui sont
stabilisées qui sont reconnus dans le
spoutnik est pas un mauvais vaccin de
près ce que j'en sais je crois qu'il ya
des problèmes de production où là aussi
je pense qu'on n'a pas intérêt à
multiplier les offres en matière de
vaccins par contre être suffisamment
achalandé et avoir à l'esprit
suffisamment de vaccins dans les 4-5
vaccin que l'on a actuellement ça me va
tout à fait je sais pas s'il faut aller
chercher si loin où le ou le russe je ne
le pense pas personnellement mais bon
déjà que nous travaillons avec
suffisamment de doses d'astrazeneca de
moderna de johnson & johnson bref les
files heures et tout ce que l'on a
actuellement et je pense qu'on doit
pouvoir faire mieux avec ce que l'on a
encore faut-il les avoir effectivement
merci philippe boutin généralistes merci
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france est toujours en france la loi
sécurité globale définitivement adopté
par le sénat la commission des lois de
la haute assemblée avait notamment
réécrit l'article 24 qui faisait tant
polémique est depuis députés et
sénateurs ont accouché d'un nouveau
texte en commission mixte paritaire le
titre même de la proposition de loi a
changé de loi relative à la sécurité
globale aloi pour une sécurité globale
préservant les libertés l'article 24 lui
ne modifiez plus la loi de 1881 sur la
liberté de la presse mais bien le code
pénal en créant un nouveau délit de
provocation à l'identification écoutez
les réactions des sénateurs on va vous
jugez impact il de votre intention
si vous avez eu l'intention
en diffusant des images de nuire aux
forces de police et aux gendarmes aux
militaires etc
écoutez c'est pas comme ça qu'on va
avancer il me semble qu'à un moment
donné il faut aussi aller à l'envers
vers la population qui a des exigences
d'éthique de la part de la police
aujourd'hui on sait très bien que les
délinquants n'ont plus peur des forces
de l'ordre et j'étais obligé les
objectifs de la de l'article 24
effectivement de rétablir à la marge
ce sentiment si je peux voir le sentez
en insécurité de verre vers l'est vers
les délinquants et de rassurer un peu
les forces de l'ordre au moins les
familles des forces de l'ordre pour ne
pas être jetés en peinture enfin en
pâture pardon sur les réseaux sociaux
divers on a bien cette polémique autour
de la mosquée de strasbourg mais préfet
du bas-rhin josiane chevalier décidé de
saisir la justice afin d'annuler
l'attribution d'une subvention à cette
construction
la préfecture qui conteste sa légalité
dans un contexte de loi sur le
séparatisme et qui fait débat les la sas
la préfecture du bas-rhin réplique
elle a saisi la justice concernant une
subvention publique de deux millions et
demi d'euros accordée à la future
mosquée de strasbourg
les échanges de courrier récent entre la
préfète du bas rhin et la maire de
strasbourg n'ont pas permis d'aboutir au
retrait de la délibération du conseil
municipal
la préfète josiane chevalier a décidé de
déférer la délibération litigieuse au
tribunal administratif de strasbourg
il s'agit d'obtenir l'annulation de la
délibération du conseil municipal dont
nous contestons la légalité
le budget de la mosquée eyyub sultan
anne qui deviendrait la plus grande
d'europe et de 25 millions d'euros
financés en majeure partie par des dons
de particuliers d'associations la future
mosquée de 16 mille cinq cents mètres
carrés suscite la polémique
son financement est jugée opaque par
certains avec des soupçons d' allégeance
envers la turquie d'erdogan
des accusations balayées par
l'association willy go russe en charge
du chantier
aucun état n'a terre faire dans les dix
neuf dans les décisions ou le
fonctionnement de la mosquée
nous trouvons qu'il est indécent et
regrettable de nous renvoyer à nos
origines
nous ne sommes pas comptable de ce qu'il
se passe dans notre pays d'origine nous
ne sommes pas et ne serons jamais des
otages des agendas des uns et des autres
nous ne sommes pas dupes
l'instrument de l'instrumentalisation
qui est faite des échéances à venir
nous avons voulu tenir cette conférence
de presse ici aujourd'hui pour dire très
clairement ça suffit la décision
d'attribuer une subvention de deux
millions et demi d'euros soit 10% du
total a provoqué la colère du ministre
de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin la mairie verte de
strasbourg finance une mosquée soutenu
par une fédération qui a refusé de
signer la charte des principes de
l'islam de france et qui défend un islam
politique
vivement que tout le monde ouvre les
yeux et que la loi séparatisme soit
bientôt votée et promulguée
jeanne bars et guingamp n'a pas hésité à
lui répondre parce que du coup c'est une
manière de dire que le gouvernement
souhaite mettre en cause le concordat et
les règles en vigueur dans notre dans
notre région dans ce cas là je pense
qu'il faut il faut le dire clairement
et si par contre il a des doutes ou des
alertes par particulière concernant le
respect des valeurs de la république
c'est aussi à lui de le dire pour ma
part j'ai fait confiance et aux
responsables locaux antérieur et aux
services de l'état avec lesquels
j'entretiens un dialogue constant sur un
certain nombre de sujets achevé en 2012
la grande mosquée de strasbourg avait
déjà bénéficié de fonds publics comme le
permet le régime spécifique des cultes
en alsace-moselle partout ailleurs en
france depuis 1905
les associations de culte ne peuvent
recevoir de subventions publiques
directes ou indirectes et pour en parler
nous sommes avec émile web adjoint au
maire de cernay dans le haut rhin en
charge de la sécurité de la politique
des quartiers bonsoir et minois et merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
le projet de construction subventionné
n'en finit plus de faire réagir et le
crémeux rebondir
ces dernières heures d'abord la justice
saisit donc par la préfète
est-ce que c'est fondé selon vous cette
saisie pour demander l'annulation des
subventions
[Musique]
d'après cet élu c'est le patron et c'est
le contrôle de légalité
si effectivement le contrôle de légalité
désapprouvent
ça me paraît normal que que l'état fasse
ceci mais après je pense qu'il faut pas
il faut pas faire un procès d'intention
à mairie du moins en tout cas la mairie
avait écologique de strasbourg ils sont
aux affaires que depuis quelques mois
et très honnêtement ce projet vous avez
très bien qu'il existe depuis au moins
dix ans la pose de la première pierre a
été fait par un grande pompe par
l'ensemble des politiques que ce soit de
gauche ou de droite
après effectivement je pense qu'il faut
laisser faut laisser les faut laisser le
service instructeur et c'est
effectivement elle appartient à la
préfète de deux régions en tout cas avec
ses services d'un tessier au pas selon
et surtout de voir si effectivement le
le bleu la construction est tout à fait
conforme ont permis qui a été délivré
alors cet examen se fera pas forcément
dans un climat très serein je vous
laisse regarder ce sondage un regard des
85% des français qui désapprouve
l'octroi de cette subvention pour cette
construction de mosquées c'est une
position qui est nabeul pour pour la
mairie un désaveu tant national que
local
moi je moi je pense que certains projets
un lieu de culte il faut c'est hyper
important qu'il y ait des lieux de culte
j'ai envie de dire dans l'ensemble des
communes de france il faut que chaque
religion puisse exercer et faire
pratiquer sa religion
bien entendu est toujours sous couvert
des lois de la république sa cet
inconditionnel et ça ne se discute pas
les lois de la république d'abord
ensuite effectivement après une fois de
plus ça reste une volonté politique
d'une municipalité mais c'est vrai que
il faut pas non plus que je pense que la
mosquée de le projet en tout cas sur
strasbourg est un petit peu pharaonique
il faut pas non plus avec des minarets
de 35 m ou 50 m il faut aussi tête au
ciel mes pieds sur terre réseaux vrd je
crois que c'est hyper important et ça
effectivement une fois de plus le permis
de construire est accordé par la
municipalité et qui est derrière
contrôlée par le contrôle de légalité
qui est les services de l'état entre
autres le préfet voir la préfète de
région
là on est on est dans le droit emil web
mais évidemment ce qui pose problème ça
n'a pas échappé à l'intérieur c'est
évidemment que cette mosquée est financé
par une association qui n'a pas signé la
charte des principes de l'islam de
france inquiète attaché à la laïcité
quel est justement votre réaction ça
pose quand même un problème je crois
qu'ils cherchent le ministre de
l'intérieur il est le guide est garant
il est garant de la loi et la sécurité
publique
si l'état si en tout cas le ministre de
l'intérieur estime qu'une association ne
respectent pas les lois de la république
il l'a fait comme il l'a fait encore
dernièrement dans ma foi il faut arrêter
de discutailler il a le droit de
dissoudre si ce n'est pas le cas il faut
arrêter voilà je ne peux pas c'est pas
c'est pas à moi d'apprécier si si cette
association
après effectivement il ya ya dans le
cadre des financements il ya ce qu'on
appelle la traçabilité très fin et ceci
et cela donc à des financements
étrangers
tout ce qui s'ensuit mais ça reste un ça
ne doit pas être un souci politique mais
ça doit effectivement toujours être en
phase avec heures avec les lois de la
république qui peuvent être
incontournable est toujours respectée
c'est un petit peu le rôle de l'ensemble
des élus en tout cas sur l'ensemble du
territoire
en tout cas la polémique sur cette
mosquée met en lumière la difficulté
évidemment beaucoup parlé à l'occasion
de ce débat de conseillers laïcité et
concordat on appelle cette loi qui a
lieu en alsace moselle qui permet de
subventionner les lieux de culte
clairement posé la question est-ce que
laïcité et loi du concordat sont elles
compatibles
aujourd'hui écoutez j'ai envie de vous
dire moi je suis je suis né en alsace
j'ai grandir l'alsace et j'ai eu la
chance d'avoir de la durant tout mon
école primaire une éducation avec les
soeurs et je peux vous assurer que je
garde un souvenir particulier est
toujours très émouvant
voilà après jeu c'est un droit je crois
que c'est un droit alsacien c'est le
droit qui est reconnu effectivement
l'alsace moselle le concordat moi très
honnêtement moi j'y suis pour
et j'y suis particulièrement attachée
j'ai déjà vite j'ai envie de vous dire
vous avec les alsaciens sont très
conservateurs très chemin des oies en
tout cas moi j'en fais partie et
particulièrement fiers donc moi pour moi
le concordat ne devrait pas en tous les
cas surgi en tout cas ce genre
d'affaires voilà entraîne une forme de
pas de suspicion mais c'est vrai que 78%
des sondés contre sont contre le
concordat à l'échelle nationale on va
voir peut-être sur sur le sondage qui va
s'afficher regarder 78% des sondés ça
fait beaucoup et seulement effectivement
52% des alsaciens dont vous faites
partie qui sont favorables à
l'abrogation de de ce régime
justement quand il s'agit de mosquées
financées par des associations voient là
où il ya une forme de suspicion parce
qu'elles n'ont pas signé la charte de
l'islam est ce que ça peut fragiliser et
ce sera ma dernière question ce
concordat auxquels sont très attachés
les alsaciens ne crois pas que il faut
pas que le bleu cette polémique en tout
cas avec cette mosquée sur strasbourg ne
doit pas il faut pas que ce soit l'arbre
qui cache la forêt je veux dire nous le
concordat pour l'instant le compara
c'est toujours très très bien classés
passé en alsace dont la preuve des
alsaciens au saut plus que fier mais
maintenant ce problème avec cette
mosquée strasbourgeoise ne doit pas
remettre en tous les cas en question le
concordat dont la masse je reste
intimement convaincu la majorité des
alsaciens isis ont trait à passer en
tout cas hemingway vas tu m'emmerdes de
cerner en charge de la sécurité de la
politique des quartiers merci à vous
d'avoir été avec nous dans quelques
instants rester avec nous d'un
revirement sur la rencontre à moscou
entre vladimir poutine et le premier
ministre arménien à nikol pashinian qui
intervient évidemment dans un contexte
de crise politique en arménie
direction le rwanda où le président paul
kagame a salué le rapport sur le rôle de
la france dans le génocide de 1994
estimant qu'il marque un important pas
en avant vers une compréhension commune
de ce qui s'est passé
[Musique]
bienvenue à novossibirsk nous sommes au
bord de la volga le plus long fleuve
d'europe
nous sommes chez vox harry
allons faire connaissance vous avez
choisi le jour à ba là on est
alors je suis arrivé en 2005 pour
étudier dernière poche la france était
en 2011
on demande pas un petit peu non ah oui
c'est tous les fromages tous les soucis
sont toutes les les croissants la
pâtisserie traits de caractère des
russes qui te plaît l'amitié les gens
les gens très stylée les français ne le
savent pas je ne pensais jamais de ma
vie faire la plonge et autonomie vous
pouvez me souhaiter bon courage
[Musique]
à très bientôt sur un terreau france
les trente ans que les cours sont
manipulés comment est-ce qu'on peut
réguler ça on ne peut pas c'est une
manipulation on va dire 2 0 la
possibilité de cette manipulation est
encore plus facile parce que vous avez
de nouveaux traders parce que vous avez
des gens qui ont été attirés par
l'argent assez facile le bitcoin
illustre quelque chose qui existe de
toute éternité gagner de l'argent en ne
faisant rien en achetant un actif qui
nous vaut intrinsèquement rien grâce à
des gogos qui n'y comprennent rien sauf
la promesse de faire fortune qui en
profitent réellement de ces
manipulations peau malheureusement c'est
pas les petites sardines c'est des
requins bleus petit particulier il est
là pour se faire prendre
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent à l on
soit vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrêmement
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interio ya pas une façon
plus pauvres de défendre un système que
de dire qu'il est moins pire qu'un autre
peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous savez
comme moi que dès qu'on dit il n'ya pas
intervenir on sort du pays
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes comment ces mecs-là
arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi je
pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose
d'inusité gilet jaune c'était des
valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la double hic
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie d'avoir un huitième
[Musique]
l'agité pour tous ce que ça rapporte aux
enfants c'est une confiance confiance en
soi ils ont soif d'apprendre et izm la
connaissance mais quelque chose les
blocs aussi dans l'apprentissage à
l'école les enfants de l'ambition ils
veulent à accéder à des gros poste
veulent s'évader du quartier qu'est ce
qui ne fonctionne pas dans
l'apprentissage à l'école les
professeurs les écoles fonds nécessaires
mais je rencontre des instituteurs des
institutrices en ce1 ce2 il ya des
enfants qui ont vraiment encore du mal à
lire et à écrire
et c'est pénalisant pour l'enfant pour
leurs familles on oublie les parents qui
sont responsables du foyer est temps que
les parents ne maîtrise et ne parlent
pas le français à la maison bas ça va
être difficile
[Musique]
21h38 les bienvenus en direct sur rt
france si vous nous rejoignez rencontre
aujourd'hui à moscou entre vladimir
poutine et le premier ministre arménien
nikol pashinian au coeur des échanges
l'agenda politique de l'arménie qui
traverse une profonde crise politique à
la suite de sa défaite militaire dans le
haut-karabagh fragilisé nikol pashinian
annoncé sa démission pour le mois
d'avril un signe des élections
législatives anticipées prévues le 20
juin et de dirigeantes abordé de
nombreux sujets tout de suite des
détails avec notre correspondant à
moscou antoine claireaux dans un premier
temps on peut souligner que le premier
ministre arménien et reconnaissants de
la contribution russe dans la
stabilisation de la situation depuis le
conflit de tonnes dernier dans le
haut-karabagh la russie est d'ailleurs
toujours présentes sur place avec des
troupes de maintien de la paix cette
visite est aussi l'occasion de
développer la coopération les relations
bilatérales dans différents domaines
comme la défense l'armée arménienne a
besoin de nouveaux équipements mais
aussi les vaccins en effet la remanier
va recevoir son premier lot de doses de
spoutnik v nous allons demain recevoir
le premier lot des vaccins russe et
j'espère que cette première à part qui
est ce un parti qui est symbolique sera
le premier pas et après nous allons
acheter beaucoup de vaccins russe comme
il est efficace ce vaccin est pour nous
il est important de faire en sorte que
l'arménie est l'opportunité d'acheter de
se procurer ce vaccin chez nous la
production prend de l'ampleur et il
s'agit maintenant de volume de
production particulièrement important et
je pense que nous devrions pouvoir
résoudre cette question
sans que les citoyens russes en
souffrent l'arménie depuis l'accord de
paix du 9 novembre a perdu les trois
quarts des territoires qu'elle
contrôlait dans le haut-karabagh ce qui
a provoqué une grave crise politique
elle annonce d'élections législatives
anticipées
mais en dépit de ces soubresauts moscou
continue d'apporter son soutien à erevan
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
l'autre blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales bonsoir que
l'autre branche maison merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france pour bien
comprendre quel est l'enjeu de cette
rencontre entre des lumières faut-il
pour nikol pashinian je crois que
l'école pacino et est venu chercher un
soutien le soutien de la dmr poutine sur
deux points
d'abord sur un pont humanitaire très
important pour la population arménienne
et ensuite un soutien politique en vue
les élections alors le soutien
humanitaire c'est dans l'accord de
cessez-le-feu du 9 10 novembre dernier
il ya une clause qui prévoit bien sûr
comme généralement après un accord de
cessez-le-feu la libération de tous les
prisonniers de tous les prisonniers de
tous les otages de tous les détenus
malheureusement le le monsieur alief n'a
pas libéré des prisonniers arménien et
pas de chignan a obtenu aujourd'hui le
soutien de poutine pour demander à bas
coût que les prisonniers arménien soit
libéré je crois que c'est un point très
important pour la population arménienne
et puis alors deuxièmement comme il va y
avoir des élections
comme vous l'avait dit au mois de juin
évidemment pas de chignan veut montrer
qu' elle est en bons rapports avec la
dîmière poutine
et ceci n'est pas tout à fait évident il
revient de loin monsieur pat chignon
puisqu'il est arrivé au pouvoir en 2018
il y a trois ans à la tête d'une sorte
de
révolution de velours d'une contestation
du pouvoir établi avec lequel moscou
entretenait de bons rapports et par
conséquent il a soulevé des soupçons de
subversion à moscou cela dit il s'est
montré homme d'état raisonnable
courageux même puisqu'il a dû accepter
cet accord du nymphée et 10 novembre
dernier l'armée arménienne était était
battu elle avait sous-estimé ses forces
et est gravement sous-estimé
l'armée qui se battait contre elle est
finalement évidemment monsieur batignole
bien a dû reconnaître qu'il n'avait pas
le choix et la signer cet accord avec
alief et avec le président poutine
lorsqu'il est revenu à erevan il a
évidemment été pris à partie violemment
par l'opposition bien sûr mais aussi par
l'armée qui cherchait à se dédouaner de
sa défaite par l'église même et par une
grande partie de la population
arménienne
par conséquent il a dû faire face il a
fait face
il a tenu bon et je crois que le
président poutine lui en sais gré donc
dans le fond aujourd'hui il a montré qu'
il était un candidat comme d'autres
qu'il était probablement acceptable sans
doute comme d'autre part par le kremlin
comment s'applique à guingamp raisons
l'accord de cessez-le-feu haut karabakh
conclu le 10 novembre 2020
alors à part le point sur la libération
des prisonniers par le verbe ajjan il y
a des points qui s'applique correctement
comme par exemple les clauses
territoriales qui sont très précises
puisque l'accord prévoit la remise à
l'azerbaïdjan d'un certain nombre de
districts qui avait été conquis par
l'arménie en 1940 en 94 en réalité et
qui constituait une sorte de zone tampon
entre le haut karabakh peu
les deux cent cinquante mille arméniens
et l'arménie proprement dit
l'accord prévoit également que 2000
soldats russes jouent le rôle de force
de maintien de la paix et par conséquent
dans les transferts de populations qui
accompagnent les transfère de
territoires qui sont toujours des
tragédies humanitaires
et bien cette force de la paix essaient
de faire est le moins de violence
possible
et puis en deuxième lieu elle est
chargée d'assurer la liberté de
circulation dans le couloir de la chine
qui est une route en réalité qui va de
l'arménie haut karabakh était un
véritable cordon ombilical pour la
survie du haut karabagh donc elle assure
cette liberté de circulation
en revanche l'accord prévoit la création
d'un autre corridor tout à fait dans le
sud de l'arménie pour relier une
province de l'arménie qui se retrouvent
séparés une province pardon une province
qui se trouve séparé de ce 202e majeure
partie de son territoire et donc 7
cette nouvelle route ce nouveau chemin
de fer peut-être reste à adé à dessiner
reste à tracer à concevoir et aussi à
financer ça ce n'est pas du tout faits
donc il ya des points qui sont
appliquées d'autres moins
et évidemment les trois gouvernements
ont désigné trois vice-premiers
ministres pour assurer le suivi de façon
à avoir une
un suivi très opérationnelle de des
clauses qui sont prévus dans cet accord
du 10 novembre dernier alors russie
arménie
peut-on parler d'un partenariat pour
l'avenir oui vous avez parlez dans votre
sujet des aspects militaires bien sûr il
y en a et d'ailleurs il ya une base
militaire russe
en arménie mais il ya aussi d'autres
aspects notamment la construction
d'infrastructures dans le domaine des
transports dans le domaine de l'énergie
et silva chez un ami probablement le
président poutine au pied du mur en lui
demandant si la russie serait en mesure
de construire une centrale nucléaire
pour fabriquer de l'électricité puisque
le pays évidemment un déficit d'énergie
je ne sais pas quelle réponse il a il a
obtenu mais en effet ce sont dans ces
domaines clés que l'arménie voudrait
avoir aussi une coopération avec la
russie
et puis par ailleurs l'arménie a deux
types de coopération multilatérale dans
lesquelles la russie joue un rôle clé
dans le domaine de la sécurité
c'est l'organisation du traité sur la
sécurité et la coopération qui date d'il
ya une vingtaine d'années et qui prévoit
une clause d'assistance mutuelle au cas
où l'un des pays est attaqué c'est
d'ailleurs cette clause d'assistance
mutuelle qui a fait que l'azerbaïdjan
n'a pas attaquer le territoire de
l'armée n'est à proprement dit il a
attaqué le haut karabakh et la zone
intermédiaire qui était occupé par
l'arménie en deuxième lieu
l'arménie fait partie de l'union
économique eurasiatique qui a été créé
il ya quelques années par vladimir
poutine qui comporte également le
kazakhstan la biélorussie l'ouzbékistan
et c'est à peu près tout et qui a prévu
d'organiser une zone d'union douanière
ça veut dire une intégration économique
quand même assez poussées et l'arménie
qui est un pays assez pauvres risquent
d'avoir des difficultés à respecter les
clauses de cette union douanière
mais en tout état de cause elle joue jeu
dans l'hôtel c'est comme dans l'union
peu économique eurasienne asiatiques
elles jouent le jeu d'un partenaire
la russie alors il faut quand même bien
dire que par ailleurs l'arménie a conclu
en 2010 est un accord de coopération
globale avec l'union européenne
peut-être est-ce la démonstration que ça
n'est pas tout à fait contradictoires
merci claude marche maison expert en
relations internationales
27 ans après le génocide contre les
tutsi au rwanda commémoré aujourd'hui au
mémorial de la shoah à paris anne
hidalgo jean michel blanquer air ou
encore l'ambassadeur du rwanda était
présent la commémoration s'est tenue au
prêt après la remise du rapport du clerc
qui pointent des responsabilités lourdes
est accablante de l'hexagone antoine
o'shea 27 ans plus tard la france assume
finalement son implication dans le
massacre
roanne dès ce mercredi le gouvernement a
annoncé la déclassification des archives
de l'ex-président françois mitterrand et
de son premier ministre de l'époque
edouard balladur
objectif annoncé faire avancer la vérité
historique
ma responsabilité elle est de veiller à
ce que ces crimes soient connus de nos
élèves et que ce soit un objet
d'histoire et que cet objet d'histoire
puisque évidemment imprégner les
consciences cet enseignement participe
de la transmission d'une culture
historique partagé qui doit être aussi
une culture historique à baiser dans un
rapport dirigé par l'historien vincent
duclert et publiée le 26 mars dernier de
nombreux télégrammes diplomatiques ou
encore des notes confidentielles
mettez en lumière le soutien que l'état
français avait à l'époque apportées au
régime génocidaire août où ce sont les
autorités françaises qui effectivement
dans ce dossier ont des responsabilités
accablante
parce que eh bien pendant trois ans au
lieu de finalement de soutenir la
démocratisation du rwanda et la paix au
rwanda au fond ces autorités ont
soutenus
l'ethnicisation soutenu la
radicalisation du gouvernement si le
président de l'association ebouquin qui
défont la mémoire du génome
deux rwandais a salué le soutien que la
france apporte au rwanda il réclame des
excuses nationales les rescapés n'ont
pas beaucoup apprendre de ces
productions négligence et le savent ils
ont vécu
ils veulent des actes forts ils veulent
que des mots sont prononcés
parce que 27 ans après certains d'entre
eux ne sont plus tout jeunes ils
attendent des nouvelles paroles fortes
quand les chercheurs de travailler quand
des histoires ils viennent de travailler
il faut que les politiques prennent
oreilles il faut que les juges auraient
les derniers chiffres de l'onu sur le
génocide au rwanda estime que sur sept
millions d'habitants que comptait le
pays en 1994 un million de personnes
majoritairement des tutsi ont été
exterminés dans des conditions
abominables
entre avril et juillet 1994 le rôle de
la france dans le massacre reste un
sujet sensible
un quart de siècle plus tard dans une
volonté de rapprochement diplomatique le
président de la république a prévu
d'effectuer une visite officielle à
kigali
d'ici au mois de mai un déplacement qui
reste toutefois soumis à l'évolution de
la situation sanitaire et pour en parler
nous sommes avec alain gauthier
cofondateur du collectif des parties
civiles pour le rwanda bonsoir alain
gautier merci d'être avec nous ce sera
fort du clair comment l'accueillez vous
un pas en avant vers une compréhension
commune de ce qu'il s'est passé comme le
dit le président mambé
oui probablement
un pas en avant c'est un rapport qui est
volumineux qui reconnaît une
responsabilité écrasante des
responsables politiques de 1994 en
particulier françois mitterrand et tout
son entourage
mais nous nous continuons à dire que ça
ne suffit pas de reconnaître
responsabilités pour nous depuis
toujours nous avons dit que il y avait
complicité
complicité de génocide complicité ne
veut pas dire que la france a voulu
le génocide mais le gouvernement
français 2,94 a soutenu le président
habyalimana et ensuite à soutenu le
gouvernement intérimaire qui a commis le
génocide
donc nous continuons à parler de
complicité de génocide
clairement comment réagissent les
parties civiles que voudrait-elle
justement des excuses alors oui bien sûr
des excuses si le président macron se
rend au rwanda
bien évidemment nous attendons des
paroles très fortes
une véritable reconnaissance de de ce
que ce rôle a été qui a été désastreux
non seulement pour l'image de la france
mais aussi pour toutes les victimes
sur le plan de la justice nous attendons
surtout que des moyens beaucoup plus
importants soit donnée au pôle crimes
contre l'humanité pour que les personnes
qui sont soupçonnées d'avoir participé
au génocide des tutsi et qui vivent en
france et bien que puisse être déférée
devant la justice en 27 ans il n'y a eu
quand même que trois personnes jugées et
condamnées et bien évidemment on ne peut
pas se satisfaire de ce bilan
nous avons déposé au collectif des
parties civiles plus d'une trentaine de
plaintes de quatre personnes sont encore
déferré devant la cour d'assises mais
dans combien de temps vont elles être
jugé cette lenteur de la justice
véritablement nous désespère et
désespère les les rescapés du génocide
c'est insupportable comment vous
expliquer justement les conclusions de
ce rapport qui parle de responsabilité
lourde mais pas de complicité c'est pour
vous une erreur d'appréciation une forme
de manque d'indépendance alors je
n'irais pas jusqu'à dire une manque
d'indépendance en ce monsieur duclair a
toujours dit qu'il travaillait
précisément en toute indépendance
mais je crois que c'est un rapport
d'historiens qui a voulu se cantonner
aux archives qui l'ont trouvée sans
vouloir aller
jusqu'à prononcer le mot de complicité
je vous ai dit que pour nous ce n'est
pas ce n'est pas suffisant sur le plan
juridique nous continuons à dire qu' il
y avait complicité
il faut quand même savoir que le set au
à l'ambassade de france à kigali que le
gouvernement intérimaire a été formé et
dans ce gouvernement intérimaire
il n'y avait que des extrémistes hutus
donc il y à une compromission évidente
avec les tueurs
alors aujourd'hui à paris paris a
annoncé l'ouverture au grand public
d'importantes archives à notamment celle
de l'ancien président socialiste
françois mitterrand au pouvoir à
l'époque génocide et outils vous en
attendez quelque chose je ne sais pas
précisément vous savez en fait nous
savons beaucoup de choses déjà nous ça
fait ça fait bientôt trente ans que on
travaille sur le génocide des tutsi avec
mon épouse on a toujours voyagé au
rwanda depuis depuis pratiquement 50 ans
donc nous connaissons bien la région
on va voir ce que ces archives la révèle
on est prêts on est prêt à prendre de
nouvelles révélations
mais je crois que l'essentiel est dit
maintenant c'est une porte ouverte à
aller beaucoup plus loin dans dans
l'histoire de ce génocide dans
l'enseignement j'ai entendu le le
ministre de l'éducation nationale par
les deux du génocide comme une matière
d'enseignement
c'est ce que nous nous faisons aussi
très régulièrement dans les lycées en
plus du travail de justice que nous
faisons pour les rescapés
clairement il ya encore de nombreuses
zones d'ombré qui résident dans cet
épisode tragique
oui il ya des zones d'ombré par exemple
rien n'est dit sur sur l'attentât qui a
coûté la vie au président habyalimana
[Musique]
je ne sais pas si les archives on disait
en dise est davantage probablement pas
oui il ya tout il y aura toujours des
choses à apprendre savez en est que 27
ans après le génocide donc il faut
continuer à travailler les historiens
doivent continuer leur travail mais nous
ce qui nous importe
et le temps presse parce que le temps
joue en faveur des bourreaux ce qui nous
importe c'est que les personnes qui sont
actuellement visé par des plaintes
puisse être jugé le rapport ne va pas
nous aider beaucoup simplement de deux
personnes que nous poursuivre en justice
sont évoqués dans ce rapport c'est
madame habyarimana qui vit
tranquillement dans son village à
courcouronnes dans l'essonne et l'ex
chef d'état major adjoint de l'armée le
colonel laurent sédogo gars qui lui vit
dans le nord
or ces deux dossiers n'avancent pas
véritablement et c'est ça qui nous
importe c'est que justice soit rendue
comment va faire la justice française
pour juger ne serait ce déjà que la
trentaine de personnes contre lesquelles
nous avons déposé des plaintes
je sais ça notre angoisse merci elle a
un gauthier cofondateur du collectif des
parties civiles pour le rwanda d'avoir
été avec nous merci on le reste de
l'actualité on part maintenant en
équateur où le deuxième tour de la
présidentielle aura lieu dimanche duel
serré entre un ancien banquier de droite
et un économiste de gauche un scrutin
sur fond de pandémie et de difficultés
économiques mathilde romagnan une
élection présidentielle à l'issue
incertaine en équateur le 11 avril les
électeurs devront choisir entre le
banquier conservateur guillermo olaso et
l'économiste socialiste andrés araoz
arrivé en tête au premier tour la
gestion de l'épidémie de coronavirus est
un enjeu majeur dans un pays à la traîne
sur la campagne de vaccination est où
l'état d'exception a été rétabli la
semaine dernière dans huit états à
écouter les habitants de quito la
capitale
difficile de prédire quelle sera l'issue
du scrutin
honnêtement je préférerais voté blanc
mais espérons que quel que soit le
candidat il offrira le changement et les
possibilités d'emploi dont les
équatoriens ont besoin la situation dans
le pays est vraiment grave à cause de la
pandémie et tout le reste
et oui nous les équatoriens pensons
qu'avec un peu de chance le nouveau
gouvernement qui entrera en fonctions
fera quelque chose pour tout le monde en
particulier le vaccin mais il devrait
vraiment être pour tout le monde car
nous connaissons les cas de corruption
qui existe avec les vaccins vip le
président rafael correa les serveurs
étages et nous devons le suivre
un héritage de travail un héritage
d'espoir et c'est ce que nous les
équatoriens voulons la crise sanitaire a
aggravé la crise économique dans le pays
fin 2020 le pib accusé une contraction
de 7 28%
face à ce constat demander à nouveau un
prêt au fmi est devenu une nécessité
mais le fonds monétaire voudra en
contrepartie prolonger une politique
d'austérité qui a déjà conduit à une
mobilisation sociale en octobre 2019
les manifestations avaient fait 11 morts
et environ 1300 blessés lors du mandat
du président sortant lenin moreno
l'ancien président rafael correa défend
lui son dauphin andrée zarauz et sa
volonté de réviser le pacte conclu avec
le fmi
ce n'est pas une relation avec le fmi
qui a été rétablie mais l'asservissement
1 ce n'est pas que nous nous sommes
retirés nous avons posé des conditions
nous avons signé un accord avec le fmi
et nous devons rendre des comptes même
si c'est un peu ennuyeux mais nous avons
signé pas mon gouvernement mais nous
avons des obligations en tant qu'etat
mais s'ils viennent en tant que membre
de la famille royale nous les renvoyons
dans le même avion
en dix ans nous n'avons pas eu ces
missions de type royal et nous avons
fait mieux que jamais il y a un an et
demi lenin moreno avait dû renoncer à
ses engagements d'austérité auprès du
fmi
face à la contestation populaire mené
par les indigènes au premier tour en
février le mouvement indigène est arrivé
troisième de l'élection
plus que jamais c'est sur leur beauté
leur approbation qu'il faudra compter et
c'est la fin de cette émission au
prochain point complet dans l'actualité
de l'actualité dans quelques minutes
[Musique]
la france